[Music]
all right listen well that was a ding
um perfect timing yeah
ladies and gentlemen we are live welcome
to the show my name is
wayne dupri i'm the host of the wayne
the pre-show and we are being
we're here we're here we are here
let me introduce you to my co-host
before we get into it
blue eyes leah bella hey make sure
you're liking sharing the show and
commenting
click the share button i always tell you
that this time i mean it
and also mr brian smith over there i'm
sharing i swear i'm sharing i'm on
facebook
hit the share or hit the like hit the
share and then hit groups
and then go down to all your groups like
40 45
of them probably not much more than that
even your cooking groups
what the heck share it to them too there
you go
well breaking news to start off
um rare
that that's why we come on at noon
because a lot of stuff happens
around this time but senator josh hawley
is the first
senator i guess i guess to say it first
yes to say that he is going to
contest or yeah contest the
certification of the electoral college
they only need one senator right yep
that opens up a whole can of worms and
he won
one congressman one senator then all the
information that they have found
everything we've ever seen that rudy
giuliani's put out
and again i was informed that we kind of
missed the boat and rudy kind of missed
it a little bit
but you know how rudy was doing that
whole thing where he was making his
rounds
and it looked like a court proceeding
but it wasn't
he was doing that to put on to display
for the elected officials
of why and how this was stolen so then
when
january 6 happens and it goes to the
floor to debate
you'll know why and you'll understand
more
of of of the cheat and where the cheat
came from and how the cheat was
what it was so it was kind of like a
prelude
and texas also filed whenever they
wanted the courts to hear their argument
the supreme court they filed it
under section 2 which was incorrect they
should have filed it under section 3
which helps trump and his attorneys
understand
what uh sections they have to file under
in order to get it directly to the
supreme court
so i'm hearing that was kind of like a
test run as well
to see what hiccups there were right so
now
the lawsuit coming that is mirroring
texas lawsuit
but is being brought by the people is
under that section because the people
have standing
and so that's the next one going to the
supreme court
i wonder i wonder how many uh
i wonder how many of the media is going
to be looking at this and say
that this is nothing too because you
know that's because that's basically how
they respond
oh this is nothing you know they're you
know they're just uh
basically uh uh pulling grasping his
straws and whatnot
i wonder where the media is going with
this yeah i actually saw an interview
today with um
one of the democrat representatives and
he was like
joe won trump needs to just get over it
this is nothing there's nothing's going
to come out of this
all the senators in the world can say
that they're not going to
uh you know be happy with election
results but the end result is
joe one accept it and move on you know
right a constitutional lawyer told me
last week he said
remember when it was uh the lawsuit bush
be gore
mm-hmm you don't see that with trump v
biden or biden b trump you know why
because biden isn't contesting any of
these lawsuits whatsoever
and he's staying out of the limelight of
said lawsuits
because you don't want to get in the
middle of that have to defend that have
to be involved in that
we're seeing now if you take the state
of pennsylvania
you look at registered voters
2016 registered voters versus the actual
vote
and then 2020 registered voters versus
the actual vote
registered voters in 2016 were huge and
actually showed trump winning
pennsylvania which we saw it
now 2020 registered voters republicans
out registered democrats 21-1
where in pennsylvania that's right 21-1
and where before that would have showed
a whole red state and maybe
lost in philly it literally
the whole state blew the one the one
they're now registering 21-1 right
wiped the democrats up on the floor in
pennsylvania
yet the whole state turned blue
penalties and all the one thing about
holly
holly to me is that holly seems
to have been holly doesn't look like he
has left trump's
camp the entire way like like
like there's some other like like mo
brooks mo brooks is saying that
he is going to support the stop to steel
thing
but then he voted
to uh um send money overseas
he voted to override trump's veto that's
you know
that's that's not cool but harley
holly seems to understand what's at
stake
the situation though is mike pence
mike is the situation because
if you look at the lawsuit that uh um uh
gomer and the republicans
have sue they sued
so that pence would have the ability
to do what what people have been talking
about
but the reason why they sued is because
pence has been leaning toward
not doing it telling pence he's got to
do what he's got to do whether you like
it or not
you gotta you gotta bite the bullet and
you got to do your job
and now we're hearing that mike pence
has just now cancelled his
uh multi-day trip to israel
and other countries and now he's gonna
stay home uh yeah
pants you need get ready you're only
couple days away buddy
i don't know i don't have a good feeling
with pets i don't
i don't either i don't have a good
feeling with him i
i mean i know but you got to do what you
got to do whether you like it or not i
mean you
you got to do your job and if your job
is
he'll find a loophole he'll find a
technicality he'll
find a way his job is what though
his job is to look at the votes and
decide
i guess based on on that's what he's
going to do
the contest from the senator and from
the congressman
that now that'll go to be debated and
it'll literally
be a court hearing if you will
in front of all the elected officials
senator hawley uh on when pledged to
challenge president-elect
joe biden's victory in pennsylvania this
is yahoo news
um the missouri republicans announcement
guarantees that both chambers will be
forced to debate the results
of at least one state and
vote on whether to accept biden's
victory a process that mitch mcconnell
had urged republicans to avoid
despite pressure from president donald
trump who was urging republicans to
overturn the democratic results
though hawley's challenge will have no
bearing on the ultimate outcome in the
election numerous gop
senators have accepted biden as
president-elect which they have
it will delay the certification of
biden's victory and force every member
of the house and senate on the record
affirming biden's win so basically that
that goes to what what you were talking
about
so are they saying that it's one did you
hear at the beginning of that though you
had said that
they can argue they're going to argue
one state but he needs more than two
states to overturn the election
yeah so this is a high hill to climb
yeah i mean well when you've got states
and and
uh zero gz pence has to do his job
certified election results
yeah that's true certify election
results and when you have
hundreds of thousands of more votes than
registered voters
uh we got a problem somebody right
now um another thing about that is
and i agree that there have been some
issues
you have to prove it you have to what
they're claiming that they
got proof of over more votes
counted when are they gonna show it
because
it's literally five days away
this is where they prove it this is all
this whole thing
is about showing this in the court of
congress
why wait till the 11th hour because
that's the rules that's the way it works
i'd be shown proof well they've been
showing proof but they were told
you're denied to the supreme court
that's what they were going to show
they've been told by lower courts denied
we're not even going to look at this
so other judges in other courts have
have just turned a blind eye to this
thing
so now the next step is to show this
evidence
to the elected officials and put it on
as if it was a court case put it on in
front of the elected office
but what a gamble they're taking what if
no senator would have said
hey i'm going to contest this then they
would have never
they would they would have never showed
the proof what else can he well rudy
giuliani made the rounds and did what he
tried
i know but what i'm saying is they're
trying obviously then somebody is
majorly
against trump which we already know
they're stifling it they're bearing the
stories
uh they can go to court until they're
blue in the face but nothing has
happened even if they do have proof
which i understand i've seen some
but what i'm saying is how can you put
all your eggs in one basket and praying
that a senator will contest it
the eggs aren't all in one if they've
been coming at different angles this
whole time around no i no you misheard
me
what i'm saying is you said that they're
holding back all their evidence they're
not holding back they're preparing
for oh okay
they're preparing to show all this
evidence and that's what rudy giuliani
was doing and making the rounds
but that's but that's what she was
asking why wait until january 6th
right that's what i'm saying i wait
until the 11th i understand the process
you're putting all your a's into one
basket right
which you know it's almost like the
hollywood thing
you know you wait until the last minute
and then the end of the world
three two one and then the clock stops
and
then everything is safe so after the
supreme court
attempting it multiple times attempting
these different judges multiple times
uh asking to be heard about
uh voter uh suppression voter fraud
more votes in their own book being able
to be heard by these judges and nobody's
giving them the time of day
right and i understand i understand the
concept but as the clock takes on
the stop gap is okay this is this is
this is where the rubber meets the road
screw all these judges now we've got the
opportunity to get in front of all these
elected officials
i understand that and i understand the
constitutional process of it i do brian
i appreciate
what you're saying and i understand what
i'm saying folks that are listening
right but what i'm trying to say is
why take the gamble on january 6th
why not put it out there but prior to
january 6. that is a gamble
out there okay okay it's been out there
yeah what's been out there all the
evidence that rudy did like a whole two
weeks of walking around
the evidence hasn't been out there they
attempted to show it in front of judges
they attempted to go to supreme court to
be heard
they were told not to i mean maybe i'll
misunderstand it but you're making it
sound like they're
waiting to the last minute and i'm
saying they've been screaming
since day one what i'm saying is
everybody that i've talked to
that is a trump supporter or follower
they're sick and tired of hearing
release the kraken and nothing has
happened
so i'm saying if you've heard if you've
seen the crack and released please tell
me where it is so i can check it out it
is
but the evidence that has mounted that
we have at hand
for more votes than there are voters for
voter suppression where we saw them put
the cards up and block out the windows
for for people not to be allowed to
watch the count be there for the count
oh hold on wait a minute i know i know
you're gonna look back on me wayne but
that's not true but
12 feet away or being in the same room
is not the same thing as standing there
and being allowed to watch
the physical votes one hand to another
hand a foot away
being there in front of each individual
ballot
being able to count each individual
that's the rules
now if they violated the rules then
let's go to court let's prove it
but what judge is allowing to even hear
the case
well well then again we're talking about
procedures
issues and that's right and there's
nothing i can do about it the lawyers
have screwed up
just to clarify i'm not saying there
wasn't voter fraud i'm 100 on board with
this i'm in pennsylvania i know how
broken
i know how quick philadelphia is and i'm
saying
where's this miracle here's the evidence
yes trump's the president
you know what i'm saying that's what i
want to see and i hate to wait for
january
with the lawyers all the evidences that
have all the documentation it's all
there
ready waiting to be presented and and
again
the one court case they went to and they
sued the wrong person
are you telling everybody in our
audience right now are you telling
everybody in our audience that
lawyers will be able to get on the floor
and explain all of the
evidence i have been informed
by a lawyer that's part of rudy
giuliani's
crew that is slated to testify
that's actually in georgia right now
he's a lawyer himself
he's in georgia right now and he's
slated to testify
he told me that all of this
will be presented as if it's a court
case
can i play devil's advocate what if
hawley says
never mind i don't want to contest what
if
i'm playing devil's advocate what
happens if you would become brainwashed
and say that
all this evidence they have gets flushed
down the toilet because they didn't
do anything sooner or they couldn't do
it or they couldn't get through to the
lawyers right they couldn't get
we have to just talk up to a crooked
system
or even as you said they sued that they
went to article two should have been
article three i agree that's a fail
going and suing the secretary of state
who has nothing to do with it
i think wayne what was that wisconsin or
something that was a fail
i mean i'm just saying we haven't these
all these judges have been corrupt so
far
and now we're going to weigh everything
on mike pence this is scary
worry thumb especially mike pence but
all the elections especially
no no no no everything falls on pence
though everything falls on pence now and
you have republicans that are uneasy
about pence making his decision that's
why he sued him
and if you have to sue him
to do something wrong
republicans are suing the vice pre the
republican vice president
because they don't think that he is
going to
right overturn the election
that's why i said all the eggs in one
basket they're putting it all in
on based on evidence of
voter fraud voter suppression too many
ballots
more ballots than there are uh people
counted
just all the the things that they have
wrapped up when they laid that all
out
and then what i i don't know i don't
know i i'm not that far educated i just
know that it's supposed to be laid
out for them i'll see i don't know
well that i mean that is the news um
and holly holly's um decision
is um sparking interest with a lot of
trump supporters right now
um when
basically i mean it's it's
it's gonna be rocky it's gonna be rocky
next week we're gonna be covering it
you know we're going to be covering it
we're going to we're going to um give
you live footage and
cup because it is going to be televised
so um
we're going to we're going to do what we
can
and um if you have questions what not
you know you can always share them
with us i don't see i i've never in my
lifetime i've seen
so much stuff i've seen so much stuff in
my lifetime
that deals with politics it's almost
like i've seen to get
i've never seen this before i've never
seen it um
and it's like and
y'all can argue with me or not but it's
like
you're fighting to change something
that's going to destroy the entire
nation
fighting to change to destroy the nation
oh yeah
like how like what trump being president
again
when things are overturned there's the
nation's going to burn
we've already said it now what about
what about law and order what about
justice
learning about what's right is right no
matter what demons don't care
i know they don't but do we dems don't
care no i know they don't they never
will but do we don't either
we don't need them well you're not
everybody
you're not everybody there's a whole lot
of people out here man chivalry's not
dead man i'm still opening the door for
a woman
oh me too okay
i still think that women are pretty
[Laughter]
i feel the right to saying that too at
times
i'll tell you what you guys are wild you
guys are wild
i'm going to say something about i was
trying to tie in michelle obama
and woman i just wanna i tried but i
don't have to be worth my effort today
oh my gosh i just is that real is that a
real picture
that's the second time i've seen that
yeah it's the second time i've seen that
yeah
yes it's ugly um for those that
for those that uh will be joining us
tomorrow
we our lines will be open it is our new
year's eve celebration show
join us for our year in review we're
going to be talking
about uh the the best of 2020
and the worst stuff to that which is a
lot oh cool yeah the best and worst
that's fun
yeah the best and worst and then we're
going to see what y'all think about
what y'all think is the best and worse
of 2020 but you got to join us you got
to join us
we start at 12 noon new year's eve
and i'm going to give you the best
advice tomorrow
on what not to eat on new year's day if
you do not want to have the worst luck
of your life
and it's the truth i'm not saying it
until tomorrow
you can try to guess what food it is but
i'm not going to say it okay
um okay so the holly holly thing
is really up there but mitch mcconnell
did something
last night with uh yesterday we were
talking about
the the uh covets uh stimulus
thing uh if there were
a vote last night it would have passed
yeah it would have passed they
four republicans said that they would
vote for the stimulus which would have
given
51 votes right the majority which is
what's his name nuclear option
harry reid very very rich nuclear option
of the 51
that could pass that if they needed it
which is a majority
pennsylvania's mic to me i i
i want you to listen to this guy because
i really never understood how dummy
this guy really no i'm serious i mean
he couldn't answer the question and then
when he answered the question it was a
dumb i have a shirt over there it says
if you
don't want a dumb response
don't ask dumb questions this wasn't a
dumb question it was a serious question
and he gave
a dumb answer if this came to the to the
senate floor as a clean vote
i think it would have the votes needed
to pass i think there's only 47
republican senators who are opposed to
it in this manner so are you in favor of
what
mitch mcconnell is doing by tying this
to things the poison pills like the
uh election fraud will be looking into
this and the 230
law repeal so there's a little bit of a
nuance and i may not have this exactly
right becky but i'm not sure that
senator mcconnell
insisted that these things all be linked
in one legislative vehicle i think what
he was describing is the fact that they
share in common
a need for the senate to do some work
here
to do an investigation to maybe go
through the committee process maybe to
debate this
and consider how to refashion this so
i'm strongly opposed to these blanket
universal checks i know many of my
republican colleagues are as well
we'd be open to how this could be
repurposed and retargeted at least
a portion of it similarly with section
230 of the communications act
um you know i think there are some
problems there i i think the assumption
that these internet platforms are just
passive
bulletin boards that allow people to
post the message and play no other role
i think it's clear that's not true and
given that that's not always true
what should we do differently but it's
not at all clear to me that you just rip
out 230 and tear it up and it goes away
i think that could have
very dramatic unintended consequences so
my point is
these are fairly complicated they are
important we shouldn't just go down to
the floor and just
have a single vote on one single aspect
of this we ought to
consider it in its uh in its complexity
and see if there's a
consensus for some path forward
but senator timmy just to be clear there
may be nuance involved in this but what
mitch mcconnell did was to make sure
that there would not be a straight vote
on the floor of the senate before
simply increasing those checks to two
thousand dollars correct right
and i agree with that what i'm saying is
i'm not saying
that i don't think senator mcconnell was
saying the only way we will consider
this
as a package with section 230 repeal and
election
reform issues in one vote i don't think
that's what he was saying i think he's
saying we're not going to do this as a
free standing measure now
let's let's consider all of these items
they're all like i said they're all
complex they're all important
they all deserve attention but i i don't
i don't think we should just have a vote
an up or down vote right now
on some really bad policy
so what he's effectively done is mean
that it it won't be
considered in this congress right um
that that may be the case but by the way
i would also point out
um it takes 60 votes in the senate to uh
to pass something and
it's not clear to me that any of these
policies have
60 votes i think we just don't know
take 60 votes if you have to override a
veto it would only take 51 votes
wouldn't it
no it's it's to be something actually
it's two-thirds to override a veto it's
60 votes under the senate rules to pass
almost anything there are some
exceptions but none of these items come
under the category of those exceptions
it would take 60 votes
then why not just vote on it because as
i said i think we it's a it's a very
very
badly flawed proposal i don't think it
has the 60 votes or certainly may not
and we could come back with something
that would have a much broader support
because it's more targeted rather than
spending
literally 630 billion dollars most of
which will go to people
who have had no loss of income
can
down is right wow
i'm sick and she was like what who
scheduled this guy
yeah i mean this guy doesn't know he's
like are you sure this is
for his i just kind of in modern senate
controversial items typically require
60 votes i knew in advance right right
typically right but we all know this
thing ain't we know this is a 51-49
right am i right well i mean that's just
the given
and that guy right there is getting 150
000 plus a year
your money of your money i'm being
i think it's 172 000. well i'm only
less than 20
well and then he gets something for life
like a pension or something oh i'm sure
he does
yeah that's that's what we got that's
what we're paying for
he said he said um first off she tried
to say
that mitch mcconnell put all this stuff
together
right because he sent it
all of it together back down to your
house
he's saying well i don't think that's
what he did uh
but that's what he did he put it all
together
which nobody told him to you don't you
uh uh the the covert stimulus is by
itself
you vote on that and then you vote on
the other stuff you don't put it all
together
that's not that's not what um president
trump was asking them to do
and another thing 600
this money's supposed to be going out so
how are y'all still
talking about it about increasing it the
to
what is it another 2 000 on top of the
600. no i think they'll just give you
the dividend of it
whatever remainder because i know people
that have already have it in their bank
accounts and they're able to remove it
on january 4th
all right yeah people have already
gotten it and uh
my friend told me i'm talking right she
got the 600 and it said will be
available on january 4th i guess there's
you know that waiting period but yeah
there's people that already have it
breitbart had an article and i was
waiting to see that but you're the first
to
confirm that well guess what yup
y'all don't kiss that 2 000 goodbye if
they've already put the 600 out there
they're not coming back with another
1400 they're not
there's not a 2000 coming there's not
why not the government isn't that given
oh
the last time that the government was
that given usually they take they don't
give
80 percent is going overseas why the
hell can't we get 25 percent and
75. why the hell is it going overseas
that's what happened
right
is insane but yeah you're right uh wayne
i don't i don't think
i think this is what you're gonna see
especially if you take it out of your
bank account
you're pretty you're pretty much just
saying i'm okay with the 600. well
no not necessarily if you owe anything
back they they're worse than the irs
they'll come take it all and forget you
not don't spend something that ain't
yours
i'm just just if you get 600 bucks in
your account
just word to the wise just hey let it
sit there for a little while
just couple months let that thing ride
out
i think you'll get the 1400 afterwards i
think everybody get two checks i think
it'll be crazy i don't think yeah
yeah are you crazy i think it's all for
sure at this point they're not getting
it
mcconnell's acting like a tough guy mr
turtle
he's acting like a tough guy and in the
end it's gonna be like well
i weighed this all i'm still gonna screw
you guys with section 230
and i mean we're gonna get it on the
back end there's no question about that
i'm not saying it's
it's a blessing that everybody's getting
two thousand i'm just saying we all
gonna get two thousand
mcconnell passes but he'll also screw us
in the end
and no no
no you you you living in um
in uh ultimately willy wonkas
yeah willy wonka oh it's very states
like strasbourg
well you've got democrats side with
trump
you got republican side with democrats
if mcconnell goes against all of this
i mean politically and it looks awful
politically it looks bad
well these guys are not they want to
politically look good
who mitch mcconnell you know mike
mcconnell could care less
he's near death i know i said that
yesterday
i know i mean and then just be honest
here
mitch mcconnell does not care and right
now he's kind of fighting with trump
and you know right no he's fighting with
trump he's fighting republicans however
when this thing comes like this uh
i'm just i'm telling you i'm just from
reading the tea leaves
and i'm just saying miss mcconnell he'll
buckle his knees he's done it for more
flight deals and he's with fang bang
bang bang
who mcconnell i don't know
he's got his
[Laughter]
oh
oh but of course um head of the
department of transportation
that's that's real funny about that fang
bang bang
yeah we like that blythe good job um
there you go she's in um trump's cabinet
true or false no president has been
treated unfairly by the u.s media
more than donald trump
true i feel like it's a trick question
it's not just in my lifetime
from what i have seen where i was able
to comprehend things
at a young age mind you i have not seen
a president
be treated this unfairly to the point
where when he got covered the media
actually allowed people
to say i hope trump dies and then
covered him directly opposite what he
was doing so yes i would have to say he
was the
most unfairly treated president i have
ever seen in my day
yeah i mean i've seen
yeah i have now now george bush was
treated bad
but but but but trump
trump was treated worse now bush didn't
have a shoe
thrown i mean um trump didn't have a
shoe going at it
no he just had ryzen sent in to him
remember when that when they sent rice
into him yeah tried to poison them
yeah they hated calvin coolidge
something fierce because tommy cool
precursor to
ronald reagan
calvin college
what year was that are we talking about
history are we talking about presidents
what
are we doing where's the jokes
just because you guys don't know about
calvin cool don't be godlive about it
okay all right all right all right old
man um
calvin coolidge was a fantastic
president and a precursor to ronald
reagan with small
federal government and they ridiculed
him
the media did however because
of what we have today with technology
with social media with all of this
it's gotta be trump i mean there's
there's no other
i mean we didn't have this kind of uh
platform
08 20 2012.
i don't i mean we were just up and
coming if you will as
the the podcasters and the audio only
and then shifting the video audio so
we've got that's why i was laughing
because i can't imagine there was much
media back then that's the only reason
why i was laughing
in the twenties yeah they're very 20s
i just huge i can't imagine i understand
that but i can't imagine
they had the emotion you know they had
to think
come on man um
i just got sent something from uh from a
special friend of mine
uh like this
now okay i just got sent something from
a special friend of mine
who sent me the message from my guest
that we had
on in the last couple of weeks from
uh a sen um what is marjorie taylor
green
she's in the house she's going to the
house or senate
brian she's in the house okay
she just she just put out um word on the
hill is that mitch mcconnell and nance
pelosi could be working together
on a rules change deal to block
our electoral college certification
objection
wow
that's not being talked about is it she
just put that out
it makes sense because nancy sees that
and notice how they waited till holly
came out and said hey i'm going to
you know wow that's
interesting to make it look like huh
um again pencils
pencils pinches princess is the linchpin
in all of it
if pink don't go along with it it's done
deal if pence goes along with it
it's a done deal either way um
go ahead go ahead old man
coolidge no it it
pence if the senators and the
congressmen if if
they can force pence's hand based on and
there's 10
there's an article written i'm trying to
desperately try to find it right now
i'll get i'll get
there's an article written where there's
10 elected officials
that are literally the
linchpin that would trigger this entire
thing
to go to wherever yeah i heard there's
11 now
we'll have to look at it try to find
that article here's the thing you
it's still pence's decision though
uh right well he can't decide against
his own people that decision
oh yes again well he could but oh my god
you wouldn't be vice president again
yeah well i want to yeah well guess what
guess what
if he if he doesn't he ain't going to be
very president
if he doesn't he's going to be vice
president that
i mean prince is done either way i don't
think he cut his own
um he's an establishment man
he's an establishment i never did like
he hasn't proven to cut his nose off
spider's face
yeah come on gracious
well i'm trying to give him the benefit
of that i haven't seen him i know you're
right
i know you are man i'm i'm playing hold
on hold on
i know we've got resurrect and i do guys
don't think i don't have reservations
about pants
i do i always have something wrong with
him he's been around long long time i
understand it
however look at back in the last four
years
pinch can only open there has been no
body
that has had trump's back and never said
a bad word about trump
first purge first purge agrees to me
he's not going to be vice president
either way
okay whatever my point is
i don't know any elected official that
has had trump's back since day one
and the only reason why i believe he
went against flynn
is because he trusted bad information
other than that
who and i and i'll give my pass on pence
pence said he wanted flint fire
based on what the fbi said and the fbi
lie depends there you go well the fbi
lie depends
well guess what pence should have went
to go look for the right correct
other than that i have not seen pence
make a mistake in a sense that
would warrant him burning trump's ship
kathy patrick asks hey leah do you think
pence wants to run
for president in the 2024 election i
truly don't
i do not see pence on the ticket i 100
don't and i don't think he has the it
factor i just don't think he has
now that we now that trump set the bar
and the president's for what's next in
comparison
does he have that it factor that trump
had does he make that impression
on you does he make you want to get out
of your seat and run
and vote does not do that for me
look and and and and and i will add look
pence is a beautiful christian man he is
he's a
christian uh what you're asking him to
do
is weigh certain things to either
and i and somebody some of y'all might
get mad i mean
saying this but uh to either
keep with tradition and go along with
everything that's being done or
change it and upset everything
in a way that it
hurts right
now we all know trump won the election
uh we know he won the election that i
mean that's
that's no question
i just wish leah i wish that
he would have used that or
that he uses that as a lynchpin
to kick off the next four years
as a battle cry he's already outsider so
now
he can run once again as outsider that's
been cheated
right and that got 72
73 million votes and stuff
uh more than any other
incumbent president of all time i i
i just wish that he would have done it
that way right and pence doesn't have it
in his dna to ruffle feathers like what
trump does let's just be honest here he
just doesn't have it in the dna he just
doesn't he's
he's completely and what's interesting
to me is they actually
paired well together because they're
completely opposite of each other trump
and pence
so they paired well together um but yeah
as for trump running in 2024
if he does i think that he still could
have a fighting chance
if he has one hell of a vice president i
think his vice president will actually
carry him to the winning finish line
versus just himself like what you're
saying so yeah i think that he would
need help in order to win 2024
um back again and i think he would need
a stronger vice president than pence i
really do believe that
one of our um donors on youtube
uh just said pence will be a step
backwards from the populist
mega agenda we need new voices
not just new faces more are apathetic
conservatives now we are all
conservative activists
for the next 100 years primarily
everybody
and if this doesn't show that there's a
third party forming i don't know what
does
i really don't i feel like the
republican party
well there's four parties out there now
there's four there's literally four
parties out there right now
uh and
the republican fourth party needs
direction leadership
and some money and to start now
because you can't start
two or three months before the primary
see
and then you can't start two or three
months before the general election
in 2024. i i mean the reason why i never
liked pence is because
of how
pence allowed paul ryan and mitch
mcconnell
to use him as a conduit between
the house and the senate and trump
mm-hmm
they went to pence whenever they had
those
uh uh um big shindig signings and went
down and whatnot
pence would be with them it wouldn't be
trump it would be pence with them
and i was like that's so disrespectful
you know
i mean and i i never you know they
caught him ted cruz like
i i you know i don't i just really
he drew in the religious vote he did for
trump let's be honest he drew in that
religious vote
and right and trump also knew
like what brian had said earlier that
pence would sit back
and allow trump to do whatever he wants
but
and at the same time he would praise
trump for whatever it is that he's doing
the one thing that i couldn't stand
about pence is when you asked him a
question it was
such a generic answer every single time
it would frustrate me
because i was so used to hearing good
answers detailed answers from trump
trump let it all out there he would open
the curtain for you and he would say
and that might have been a downfall that
he was too transparent but the problem
with pence was
he was too cookie-cutter with everything
it's it was like as if
everything in his head was already a
pre-written statement that was just
generic enough to put out there
and that was my problem with tr with um
pence it was just too generic
i'll find out some more information but
apparently the guy that i'm the lawyer
i'm talking about
listening to the show so hey lawyer i
didn't get permission to call him out
but he said that it's 10 legislators
state legislators
they can call this all into session and
it does not
hinge on pence state legislators
right they can call this an assassin and
it doesn't hinge on pets
within a thing right
10 state legislatures right that doesn't
have
that's not congress that's state
correct and it doesn't hinge on pence
and tactically
i've talked for a while uh january 16th
the end date tactically
january 20th is which is inauguration
day
however uh if we don't have a president
then
it's offered to pelosi i'm saying hold
up it's offered to her
she can turn it down if she doesn't turn
it down she accepts it
she gives up her seat if she gets her
seat again
she gives up her seat as speaker of the
house and she gives up her
uh job in congress meaning what if she
accept the temporary position as
president
once that's over she's completely out
that temporary will become
permanent
well it can't be permanent but anyways
so if she's accepted which i don't think
she will
because she knows the game and that
she'll lose everything behind
then it goes to grassley grassley
we think he'll take it because he's old
why not that's
i played this game before if grassley
doesn't take it
it goes to pompeo so basically what you
are saying is we have a constitutional
crisis
no you follow the rules of the constant
no it's all laid out and there's no
crisis it's all laid out
i don't want our country to have to go
through that that
well i mean i think i'm not saying i
want right we want that or not
those are the rules and that's how it
plays out i'm just saying
don't hit the messenger yeah i know i
just don't think it will get to there
i really don't i would be willing to bet
everything that it doesn't get that far
to where pompeo
i mean i don't know at this point in
time i don't know what's gonna happen
i can't predict the future i can only
look at the rules of the game
or maybe since calm down and the rules
of the game are
xyz i predict nancy pelosi passes it up
because she won't pass up her seat
and speaker the house goes to grassley i
don't think
grassley will take it think about
holding up think about it
you're hoping and wishing but democrats
love power though
democrats love power you think nancy
will pass out speaker the house anderson
to be temporary i mean it's just a
temporary potus
do you you don't even go down in the
books as
is no no no no no no no no because i
asked that question he said hold on
when reagan went under the knife for the
bullet
yeah they tapped h bush
he was temporary president and in the
rule books
he's only president once not twice no
but but
but but that was acting president
that's what you would be you would be
temporary acting president you wouldn't
be
in the books as number 46 well then the
next would be 47
you wouldn't be a number but that's
difficult though it has to be different
because
there would not be a president so
what do you think has a higher rate but
there wouldn't be a president
you you have to ask somebody right you
would be acting
be temporary but you have to have
somebody in there
okay okay like they tap bush h bush to
be president
while reagan was out so what do you
think the percentage of happening more
is
pelosi being acting president or them
just voting
and saying that joe biden's the next
president
you see i'm saying this could go
completely opposite where they haven't
they have an arc this is what i
they have an argument they have an
argument
they contest the election they have an
argument and then at the end they say
well joe biden's president then what
how much stuff could nancy sign into law
how fast could she get that paperwork
well they already got the paperwork set
up
i'll see you guys i'm saying we need our
insurance policy and that's georgia
we have to win georgia i've been saying
that for three months
just in case you just never know you
never mind
well of course there's like four people
there
wayne let's see what a 180 million votes
wayne be fair everyone loves power
mcconnell has a knife in trump's back
before he is out of oh uh oh i believe
that
absolutely i don't doubt that for uh for
one split second they're all dirty
bastards
i've said i've said that i don't like
mike pence but i damn sure i don't like
mitch mcconnell
yeah if you if you had mitch and pence
in a room together
and you could hang out with one of them
i sure as hell not hanging out with
mitch mcconnell
broke back congress oh no yeah
somebody said that did you oh no up in
the middle back in the woods boy
broke back congress i wish i could quit
you
um he got pretty bad
it's okay go straight to that
um i don't know whether y'all have seen
this but
three it three people were arrested
for the beating and brutal torture
of a former gop republican
senate candidate oh my god
this uh let's see wait a minute where is
uh
i thought i printed it out
they don't get massive prison time for
that
wow that's a that's a hate that's a hate
crime
the story was that she was
called on her phone
and told that she had to meet them
for some shocking information
and when she got there they beat her
almost to death apparently she said
she did survive um
and i will have more on this tomorrow i
thought i had it
i thought i printed it out and i didn't
and i'm hate crime
yeah yeah this would be breaking news if
it was a former democrat senate
candidate
for sure for sure or if it was a
democrat
does she look i think she is
mad yeah i think she is where's the
movement
yeah i know right oh no that that died a
long time ago
where where's the women's march right
yeah
equal rights equal protection equals
something
yeah y'all sent me this
information yesterday dc passes a bill
to immunize children without parental
knowledge
for unlawful carnal knowledge what no
knowledge oh
your children will be vaccinated without
your permission or with your knowledge
correct is that what it's saying i'm
saying you don't have
yeah they passed it saying that parents
don't have to be notified
so they can walk into school and then
they're going to get called down to the
auditorium they'll line up and everybody
gets shot in their arm
you can have an abortion in california
as a young
minor without your parents knowing so
how do you feel audience how do you feel
about your child
now going to go to school and could
technically get a shot in their arm of
the vaccine
and you have no say in it in fact
they're not even going to let you know
it's as if they're i mean they even let
you know what's on the menu in the
cafeteria that day
what about if you're kidding me what if
your kid needs an aspirin they can't
what if you're kidding allergic to
specific things and carries an epipen
how can they not inform you this isn't a
very alarming story
and a bill was passed you said that
that's that's where
the article said the article said the
democrats pass it it doesn't mean that
it's law doesn't mean it's going to go
anywhere it just means democrats are
good with it
let somebody stick a needle in my kid's
arm see what i'd do
see what i'd stick in them it's not
going to be nice i will
f you up this side of tuesday oh my god
you couldn't even understand you
remember that bulldozer we showed that
just drove through
buildings yeah i followed you
that would be me ugly me you don't mess
with mama bear protector
yeah that's what mama everybody knows
that if the pta is in on it i'm going to
find
their addresses and i'm going to pull
those doors
look mom you're over here harper valley
pta who sings that
mama's mama's in the south be like you
stuck
what now
[Laughter]
did you start with what now um
yeah that's right
you know what's funny um my
my daughter's guidance counselor and her
husband are a big fan of the show
and they're probably watching right now
uh and i know for a fact that she would
be totally against this
that's why i love you okay but she
watches the show i'm sure
right right yeah so i definitely know
for a fact that
i don't think our school is going to be
doing that guidance counselor
guide those children correctly yeah you
know what welcome the needle
i am really loving my brother my brother
my brother just
uh i saw that don't just donate it again
he said
i'll consider it an assault on my
child's body
and will respond with extreme prejudice
i like it something on to my child yeah
yeah i mean
you could you don't want nobody from
school to touch your child let alone
putting the needle
in them you know they're putting a
chemical
putting inside the body of the child
what kind of chemicals you put
in there i don't i don't like it it's a
minor they're my responsibility not
yours
but what if they have some type of
uh reaction right they get home and
the school don't alert you you'd be like
johnny what's wrong i don't feel too
good what
right they don't verbalize too that they
had a shot sometimes kids don't
tell you the important you know subject
of why they're not feeling well
they can't you know put two and two
together oh i had a shot in my arm today
i'm not feeling well they can't do that
i don't know my stomach hurts mom you
know you have to get it out of them
your child passes away you win a
multi-million dollar lawsuit and then
whatever
but what a million i would give you 50
million dollars to get my child
back don't don't pay me in the end
this ain't no this is this ain't ruby
ridge where you kill my dog my son and
my wife
and you give me 2.5 million dollars we
ain't called ruby ridge now right
it honestly sounds like something the
ccp would do i mean let's just be honest
right now
virginia will be offering illegal
immigrants legal driving permits
starting
january you know what their reasoning is
same reasoning in california motor voter
laws
california tried to pass bills saying
that oh
they're gonna drive just like the
condoms they're gonna drive anyway
and since they can't get insurance and
they're illegal
at least we can get them documentation
and they can get the
insurance so then now you know at least
you get paid when they run you over and
kill you
that was their uh
so now we're looking at virginia well
they're going to do it anyways so you
know
might as well make them leak this makes
a lot of sense why george soros was
hanging out in virginia
because he was he was doing a lot of
stuff in virginia george
old soros that makes sense now don't
think this isn't coming across
multiple states yeah i mean this is just
something
it's an evolution if you will in the
democrat
mind that this is how we evolve things
are just
always fluid look at the good news
illegal immigrants are having a
wonderful year because what they got
twelve hundred dollars for stimulus this
time around yeah they got about
everybody yes everybody got 600 i'm sure
their bank accounts today illegal bank
accounts have twelve hundred and
and now they get to drive come january
one this is just like the year of
illegal immigrants
celebration i knew a family
that contacted my wife by she goes both
ways with the language she speak english
and spanish
uh and they contacted my wife that was
talking with my wife they were trying to
buy a house
and they told my wife well i got 50 000
cash want to buy a house
but we contacted the real estate agent
agents like
i don't care how much cash you got you
gotta prove where the money came from
hey long story short they was illegal
and they couldn't buy a house
so what'd they do they waited five years
to their
15 year old son was 20 or 18 or whatever
returned five years later
he was of age somehow they said how he
got the money and they wouldn't bought a
house cash
50 credit wow
out of getting corona checks oh i'm
positive i got growth checks
luke leto died
tuesday evening from complications with
covet 19.
he was about to be the state's youngest
u.s congressional representative he died
at the hospital 41 years old
they said complications from covet
19 he had been admitted to the hospital
on december 19 with covet 19 symptoms
moved to the intensive care unit on
december 23rd
uh from what we have been able to
determine
he was given the same uh
radissamer from the severe
rendition that president trump got
but uh afterwards he
he uh he fell into a cardiac arrest
what a tragedy what an absolute tragedy
wow and i guess by the picture survived
by a wife and
two two fairly small children one an
infant
one might be about four or four years
old 41
41 years old and as you can tell
he's not overweight no he looks like
he's in decent shape
he did not have high blood pressure
pressure he did not have diabetes
he did not have cancer he did not have
in fact any underlying conditions
his wife said
so yeah
and on top on top of let low
massachusetts republican party leader
tom mountain uh
claims that he has covet 19
and he was just at the white house
christmas party
hanukkah hanukkah party uh
and he said that he didn't it he said
let let's put it this way when i went to
washington dc for the white house
hanukkah event i was perfectly fine
three days later after the event
i was in the hospital ready to be put on
a life-saving
ventilator okay
so what can i break something down real
quick because it's so interesting to see
and i understand that people are so torn
um
some people in this comment section said
hey you know what maybe if he followed
guidelines he wouldn't gotten sick or
gotten ill
other people say hey his heart could
have already had damage though and i
understand
both sides are trying to justify why you
should wear a mask and wash your hands
and i understand the other side that hey
what if
he could have this or he could have had
this this is what i can say about this
virus and i think it's probably the most
fair thing that you will ever hear and
this is just the reality of it
okay we cannot
continue okay let me let me just start
with this
this is a virus that's invisible and
it's highly contagious
and it is going to kill people we are in
a pandemic
that's just the reality of it i don't
know if it qualifies for a pandemic
if i can finish my thought process that
way i can actually finish a sentence
like why can't she finish a sentence
well it's because i keep getting
interrupted
go ahead yeah but anyways back to what
i'm saying is the issue
is the fact that when you get a society
that have comorbilities you're going to
see
these issues happen so with that being
said
coven 19 will be here
for longer than what we think we think
that this is going to go away in three
months it's not
okay covet's going to be here for a
while the vaccine just isn't going to
totally eradicate it
and i understand what both people are
saying covet is real
but covet isn't real enough to where
it's killing all of us
i've had it twice i know family members
have had it i also know 23 year old that
had to get her leg cut off and then she
died three weeks later
so i the problem is the experts don't
know what to do
we're still doing this they don't really
know they know that if you wash your
hands in social distance enough
and wear a mask they think that this can
actually
help the spread and this is what i tried
to explain earlier in our other
conversation that i was having wearing a
mask social distancing
and washing your hands does lower your
risk
how much i don't know i'm not a doctor
but i can tell you if you're standing in
a room with someone for eight to twelve
hours
and you both have your masks on and one
of you have covered you're probably
going to get coveted
because this is also a time issue as
well it's a numbers game
there's no right and there's no wrong so
i don't want to hear this is
this is definitely what you have to do
to save lives or this isn't what you
have to do to save lives
the issue is we have two conflicting
problems
one is you're going to kill the economy
and two is you're going to have people
die
so i think that we have to find a happy
medium we have to open back
up but we have to do it safely as well
and that's the end of the story but if
you have people that don't want to do
that safely
you're going to have more deaths social
distancing and masks and we still have
spikes
in cases through the roof yet we have
lowest fluenza that we've ever had in
how many years it just doesn't make
sense the numbers across the board
the hypocrisy in the medical community
the hypocrisy
from one section and one set of doctors
to another section another set of
doctors
and as i was saying before to classify
this as a pandemic
is political when you've got something
that we're
97 98 survival rate
uh that's not necessarily a pandemic
i mean if we had a 94 survival rate of
the cancer patients
we'd literally be closing every single
cancer institute out there
because it would be a successful uh
healing of people in cancer yet
we've got 97 plus percent i think it's
96 percent if you're 70 and older
96 survival rate and to shut the world
but to shut the world down like they're
doing and now they're talking about
shutdown 2.0 i'm not buying it look i
agree
with you and that's why i asked you
yesterday and i want a straight answer
why are we shut down to save lives or to
help the hospitals
without saying i heard that hospitals
aren't packed
that's my big question and if they are
in 100 capacity
the right answer is because they don't
have a freaking clue about this virus
falci's a dumbass and the rest of them
are too they don't have a flu
they don't have to worry about papyrus
they don't understand if it's
respiratory
if it isn't respiratory if it causes
inflammation
they don't understand anything about
this virus and that's the problem and
they're so damn focused on getting on
cnn
and telling you what you should not be
doing instead of sitting down and
figuring out
what on earth are we going to do with
this virus because i can promise you
another thing the vaccine is probably
only going to be
70 effective against this new strain so
what do we need we need an antidote
we need something that we can take that
can fight this virus until we can
eradicate it because this vaccine is not
the be
all save all it's not now you've got
london saying
you got london saying that the super
strain is coming
we got it and that's not
and scientists are too busy tweeting out
either don't wear a mask or wear mask
when instead they should be figuring out
what is the right answer there's no
nobody knows
there should be a lockdown on doctors
to shut the hell up yeah you know
they determine
what is fact and what isn't fact because
the doctors i
i'm not saying that the book see some
people out there say that the doctors
are being political i
i have never thought that my thinking
has always been the doctors
think doctor wise they think we have to
save lives this is what's going to do it
that's where we are the politicians are
the ones
that make it political they are the ones
that have taken power or
have pulled in power from these states
uh president trump president trump is
also responsible
for a whole lot of stuff that is
happening right now because he was given
the information
maybe he he was given
about his information bert's information
maybe he should have had another doctor
in there giving him the other side
but he took that information and said
okay let's run with that
that's his decision as president united
states
i mean and they set him up with the
ventilators they really did he was over
here looking at the ventilators we have
stockpiles and stockpiles of ventilators
and we're not even using them
because that's not what solves this
problem okay we don't want to get on a
ventilator that's not a good thing oh
and remember
that's not trump didn't know that he's
not a doctor
valencia they're telling him to make
ventilators which was wrong remember
faucet told us not to wear a mask then
to wear a mask
but like you said the doctors don't know
so they only go on um experiences of
what they have done before but they
don't know and that's why i said
the doctors have to go into a room shut
the hell up lock yourself
into uh lock yourself in there and find
and then come out together
as as as a very important
um response and says this is what we've
come up with but
but they haven't because you have
people on the conservative you have
doctors on the conservative right
that are coming here and saying nope you
don't have to do anything the maths
don't work and all that stuff and then
you got the people on the left that says
well the mess works for us and
hazmat suit me and and well i don't know
about the hashmaster but
this is uh we just want to be safe so
then it becomes a political bowling ball
between or a political kickball between
both
and people are dying people are dying
people let low 41 years and it's
not the old people and whether y'all
uh and something that's not getting
really put out there
minorities are dying from this thing
minorities
are dying from this covet
and then they are they want the
minorities to go ahead and and
and uh when they weren't they starting
to roll out in the minority communities
with the vaccine
they intentionally wanted to hit that
community first
yeah and they were like nope right i i
think there's something messed up
and i just find it funny that they're
not doing psas on what you can actually
do
i've had kova twice i'm going to tell
you right now 5000 ius
of vitamin d take your vitamin c take
your zinc don't eat any uh
dairy products because it causes phlegm
and lay on your stomach get yourself a
pulse ox
that's the best thing you can do but i i
don't hear any of them talking about
that
it's like they want you to get sick i
don't know
it was the first uh the first prayer
says one in 500
black people have died from covert
that's huge
we were looking at the no we were
looking at the numbers but
nobody's nobody's reporting on that
though
nobody nobody's reporting on that
because
people on social media is like ah 98 99
surviving well you know looking at other
people
you're not looking at other people
you're looking at
certain and and and i don't
i i blame this on ignorance but like in
a court
in a in a court thing ignorance ignition
is no excuse
you can't just throw everything out with
the bathwater
you just can't say well this works for
everybody because it doesn't work for
everybody because everybody's not saying
everybody's not the same so
i have always given and i know
my co-hosts hate vouchers me myself
well maybe not hate they just don't like
him
as amanda's been in the same government
position for 37 years
i got a problem with it i don't like it
because he lied to us he's like
three times he panders to whatever he
thinks that we need to hear
that's not cool i mean you know the
surgeon general also lag yeah i don't
like him either the surgeon general
awesome i watched him lie yeah he did
lie
about faith yeah he did so i mean
but doctors back in the day said menthol
cigarettes are good for your throat
but you crazy but then
but even though you said that they lied
you go back
to what you said before they don't know
they don't know yet
and then they don't they can't suck up
their pride and admit it we
we are with this this is the first year
with covey
first year and
and it's oh we didn't figure it out they
didn't figure out
the flu in one year you looked around
for a long
time you know did they ever actually
figure out the flu of 1918 i mean they
actually they didn't eradicate that it
just kind of went
yeah they never figured out that one
flu vaccines and you were telling me flu
changes and morphs
well yeah it is what it is and many
and many people are out there saying
well the flu numbers are now actually
the
the flu numbers aren't down the flu
numbers are probably the same that they
are it's just not being reported
they're added are a lot of people out
there that are get
that are getting negative covet results
guess what
yeah i got the flu probably you got the
flu
it i mean if it's if it's knocked you
down you
ah okay yeah and then you go to your
doctor well it's not covert
well and mathematically speaking if
you're social distancing the flu isn't
half as contagious as what covet is
so therefore you would see cases of the
flu go down this year
because we're all separated from each
other the covet and blue
have two different contagions they're
not as
contagious well they're saying that is
not
if you're not if you're asymptomatic you
can't get it so it's kind of like the
flu
but that has nothing to do with it i'm
saying the flu is is not
as contagious as covered cove is more
contagious than the flu that's just a
fact
i mean obviously or we'd be shutting
down for the flu fluid
well i mean we're having 56. i've never
had to die
when i moved to maryland i didn't even
know there was flu tests i thought the
girl at my work was lying her name's
megan
and she was kind of like a compulsive
liar anyways so whenever she called in
and
yeah whenever she called in and said oh
i just got tested for the flu this was
2010.
i laughed and i said to my boss what a
compulsive liar there's no such thing
and she was like yeah there is
i didn't even know there was such a
thing as a flu a and b test that swabbed
your nose
i never had it never had the well i mean
i've never had the flu
test but i knew that the flu was around
everything i was a little
kid i knew that what do you mean i'm
saying i didn't have it
oh okay okay well yeah i knew that there
was a flu
my whole family doctors and nurses yeah
i don't think that brian maybe maybe
maybe maybe we need to stop eating
mayonnaise
that's it mustard and ketchup and
ketchup i've never had ketchup either
condiments make an entire meal i do
never tasted coleslaw never had macaroni
salad
there it is deviled eggs nope i don't
know
blue everybody had the flu yeah
you know if you didn't know you had it
you had it i just didn't
i called bs leah i'm telling you i've
never ate any of this
too no never maybe you were never
diagnosed with it but i'm sure
okay that's fine then maybe i did have
the flu i'm past that i'm just saying no
yeah i'm saying i know i had good weight
twice oh you mean like
you having covert and not knowing that
oh no i tested negative
oh i i had it twice yeah i tested the
negative
results all right he had it yeah
well then he had the flu yeah
you know and i've been thinking about
that too i why didn't they test me for
the flu
that kind of irritates me i told you
that's why it flews down because they're
not tested for it
that is exactly why flu's down they're
testing for coconut and then things get
fun
and i'm sick they're saying okay we're
going to test you for covid they're all
worked up covered kovachov
test your copa they send you home they
call you back in three days and say hey
it's not the flu
and then they don't test for the flu
yeah they're not called
it's not one up here they're not calling
the flu covert
yeah i'm hearing a lot of people being
labeled as coving
but they can find a trace well because
they analyze it too
well then they might be coded well then
it would be crazy
but if you find a treasure they call
kobe but
if it's not covered they will let people
know
there's a whole lot of people out here
that are getting negative results
right you gotta get false positives from
the covet
flu and false negatives too
i don't know i can't all i say is when
are we going to be out of lockdown i'm
about not when the politicians say we
are we are the doctors the politicians
i i mean i i don't believe i don't
believe that i don't believe that we're
going to be on lockdown i really don't
because of what happened over vouchers
calling for it and so is by
no fouch is not calling for it buying he
just said that it was the second round
that's even worse
but he didn't call for a lockdown he was
talking about what's going to change it
though why what would make us come out
of lockdown
come out yeah like what would stop the
lockdowns from happening
how can we get out of a lockdown because
they are afraid of what happened to the
economy
no i'm saying when is it going to happen
well biden was like he
he wants americans to wear biden wants
americans to wear
a amassed the first 100 days yeah
that he masks aren't the end-all be-all
savings
exactly right so that's dumb and again
that doesn't get us out of lockdown so
what gets us out of lockdowns
well i'm well we're not in lockdown
right now so okay well i am so
what gets me out of lockdown come down
from the mountain
governor wolf what gets me out of
lockdown pennsylvania's asking
marilyn put patricia to me out of her
misery
look what i'm trying what i'm saying is
this is rough
there is no end there's no end game
we're not in lockdown
so i don't i mean you gotta get a
different guy up there in your health
department
pennsylvania health advisor you got to
get a different guy that because that
guy ain't working
about it kathy's been locked down that's
what i'm not saying
well we're people's republic yeah
california forget about it
um boxes of beauty says when president
trump says in office
okay all right president trump no no
no i don't know no i don't have
confidence in that
no because she's been locked down now
and president trump's in office
the lockdowns don't have anything to do
with president trump anymore that's what
i'm trying to say
he was calling every day on twitter i'm
saying this was fearful
i'm seeing my friends and family members
say oh here's two better 2021
hoping for a better 2020. what gets us
out of this
what gets us all this because the
vaccine is not the answer when the
people
finally say enough is enough and won't
go your own way
you already know what i'm worried about
oh i'm not seeing that
i'm just saying 1.99 these stores
are all strapped up with the face mask
nobody's fighting the rules here in
cincinnati nobody i don't know
i don't believe that i'm gonna start
scoping for now on when i go to these
stores i
am harassed i'm chased out well it's
insane
well then what you need to do is follow
store policy
now i just go to the stores that don't
care okay where they go
when do we get back to where we don't
have to wear masks that's what i'm
asking
no one knows just don't wear them now
most of the people that were initially
diagnosed as
a covert 19 case were diagnosed off of
symptoms not a test the symptoms are
similar to the flu yeah
that makes sense ace thanks ace
ace this show is being brought to you by
ace
yeah it's your favorite intellectuals
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's the hardware place yeah man he is
i'm just putting out a warning for
people you think you're crazy now wait
till march and april come and they're
still doing this to us
that's my big concern i want to see some
advances and i'm not just talking about
a vaccine that they're wishy-washy on
the flu is similar to the flu
that's profound i said i make a call to
everybody
follow me and be a non-participant
i'm not even participating anymore i'm
not involved
just don't be involved just go about
your life
i it's not i think again i keep missing
my point
my point i don't care about the mask and
i don't care about going shopping my
point is my businesses aren't open here
i'm not involved in it brian so what do
you want me to do
i don't have a partner i don't know
about you i'd like to go to a damn bar
i don't so how do i know pittsburgh
probably not it's all shut down the
casino was shut down
so i'm saying to you that's great if you
want to brag about not wearing your mask
and
being mr tough guy that's great i know
it's not tough it's just about
no i'm just i'm using that example but
i'm saying i'll do it with you i'll
right right with you without any masks
but we're saying here
well they're not over here that's what
i'm saying what do i do in pennsylvania
come to cincinnati you people are
delusional nobody
wants to wear masks it's stopped the
spread
it a mass just doesn't stop the spread
that's delusional to say that
it takes more than just that it takes
social distancing it takes well in your
hands
it takes all that stuff but department
right yeah it's a cocktail right it's a
mixture of everything but the problem is
you can only handle so much of this to
where it becomes an issue
and my issue is look at southern
california that is alarming to me
they've done it and they're packed
across the board
they've had the strictest roles
they're inundated with with this covet
are we strapping again no no no i'm
proving a point
this is and everybody doesn't get it
you're right um they're saying rh
negative people don't get it
this is conservatives right no no that's
going to work
there's a lot of people at the stores
that are working there that do this
after eight hours of working there
well over here they do masks don't work
i had a mask on i found hair salon for
two hours and i got super dizzy
i cannot get it that don't work they
don't work
no they do work if they worked then
california wouldn't be on a lockdown on
a lockdown on a lockdown
a lot a whole lot of people in
california don't wear masks
uh that's not legal remember
what you're saying to put out a blanket
statement that masks don't work or do
work
the issue is they work for a point but
once you spend six to eight hours with a
person that has coveted and you're face
to face with them
it doesn't work as well so masks do work
to a point
but they don't work after a certain
point and
we don't i believe that right i do
believe that
for a person non-doctor
to come out and say mass don't work at
all they don't work as
ridiculous that's crazy it is crazy
that it don't work at all then i'm like
well i've seen i've seen yeah but it's
the micro molecule
whatever people whatever if you don't
want to work don't wear it
and i can say this is how a masks work
work okay if i'm talking and i
spit and i have covid and it falls into
your mouth
you're probably gonna get coveted if we
have the masks on and i'm not social
distancing and i spit
that spit's not gonna get your mouth
because the cloth actually does stop it
that's just a fact that's just a fact if
i hawk a loogie
and i'm i'm within five feet of you it's
gonna go there dude
it's not a headshot it's gonna happen
nasty yeah
hamas is not going to kill everybody
nascar is not going to save this country
and a match is not going to save you
from getting coveted if you're around a
person
for more than two hours it's exposed
time a mask
is supposed to work
with many other things that's right but
the i mean but the main thing is
remember about the social justice
because you just don't know you got
people this
this um this republican leader says that
he didn't have it before he went to the
hanukkah event he don't know that
he could have had it before he went to
the hanukkah event i gave it all up
and gave it to the people that was at
the event
did they say it takes a few days for it
to show up but
right right but then he said that when
he went there
at least 80 to 85 percent of the people
of people weren't even wearing the mask
they weren't even practicing social
discipline if you aren't practicing
and and um
how many of y'all remember how people
said hey get out of space get out of my
space
you know two feet three feet whatever
people have space personal space yeah
they got personal space so i mean but
but
then when you see the left doing their
major marches when you see the right
doing their major marches even um even
the march
or or this event um next week
when an organizer said don't bring a
mask
a man so you know
now that's as an organizer that's
actually irresponsible
yeah it is that's irresponsible it is as
an organizer i would say
if you feel like you need a mask make
sure you bring one
all right if you don't feel good stay
the flip
home yeah don't come out yeah
responsibility y'all but see that's
that's one of the main issues that i
have with a whole lot of people is that
they know they don't feel good
but then they end up going to places
where they're friends and stuff
and then all of a sudden somebody's sick
going to work and giving it to your
co-workers that's crazy
because i know during flu time or just
when you get sick
they will send you home yeah they will
send you home really no no
no because you don't look good get the
hell out here
right but you know all this controversy
it's because
we don't have anything set in stone from
our doctors
uh fauci keeps flip-flopping and my
biggest question on all this is
why is it you can get on an airplane
take off your mask and eat your dinner
but you can't go to a restaurant
well what aircraft you're getting on
yeah exactly
exactly right they are nazis
well my cousin flew and he was able to
take off his mask and eat it and eat
i
because he was in coach because he was
in first class and he was able to eat
i'm not j
i'm not joking yeah well
i'm just ready
it's not fair that people in first class
can take off their masks
let them have it they pay they pay
thousands of dollars oh but restaurants
can't be open you know it don't cost i
know only people in first class are ones
with connections i know how that works
that's a crap
but but but american airlines
thanks sherry no i flew i flew american
airlines to florida and back
and they were extremely
strict so strict that they would be like
yeah they walked up and down the aisle
they said sir
and i had the nose i had the nose like
this they said sir
up over the nose come on now oh i didn't
get the upper nose thing but uh
but i did eat uh you know some doritos
and stuff like this and then when i get
finished
they play just put it back right their
lines ain't playing you just don't fly
there
seriously i mean don't you think
restaurants should be open then if you
can eat doritos on a plane
yes okay
what i'm trying to say is they don't
know that that's true
did you really yeah wayne just said no
restaurants shouldn't be open
no because they can deliver no they
can't i know like 12 restaurants that
can't deliver
look tactically you could get in the car
and drive it to somebody but
i know you're ran by two people
two people susie q just said
i just got my direct deposit of six
hundred dollars grateful for it but it's
not 2 000.
there's the news on this uh-oh
be careful i better check let me check
let me check
i don't like i don't like the government
having access to my bank account
anyway like that well i mean there's
it's a one it's a
well it's supposed to be yeah i have one
right
right unless they get an order from the
judge from accord
otherwise they can't go reverse
they can't reverse take money out
without a joke oh crap
bull crap they can't oh they have to
have a judge they have to have the
documentation
paperwork you can't just suck money out
just like did the government
lead the government
whatever they please they can walk down
the country if they want
they can make you wear masks
no there's more airflow on a plane
that's what somebody said that's why you
can't eat in restaurants because there's
more airflow
you was wrong
nastiest air that's why you can speak
naturally
that's on an thing i've ever heard thank
you
for making me laugh t-rex that was great
bro oh you think they opened the window
30 000 feet oh hell man a little chilly
up in here
no i'm doing it is this crank windows or
power windows now
stewart this was the in-flight movie
right can you
can you turn the heat back on it'll be a
little pretty good
i know we're 30 000 but you know air
feel a little thin up here
yeah it's so much more fresher air than
a restaurant
oh my gosh t-rex that is hilario rex
rex retrex that's the name can you
imagine some of those restaurants i
don't know if you have not where you're
at where they
like a wall of the restaurant will open
up to the outdoors
yeah yeah that's so cool yeah just like
the airplanes
right the airplanes just open up their
walls oh my gosh
real quick real quick before we leave
for the day
uh our new year's show will be
tomorrow 12 noon eastern standard time
join us
for our year review we're going to be
giving away a hundred dollars
to my i know
we might give away 200 300 i don't know
yet
but um i won't make up my mind until
later on tonight when i look at my
account
uh maybe if they give me my 600 i'll
just give it out i don't care
um but download our app
our podcast app and uh
yeah message waiting to free podcast
just type it into your search engine
it'll download with
just in seconds and then you can click
on podcast you can also if you look at
uh four down it says message studio
that's where you're gonna send us a
message through
and you can watch previous podcasts as
well but you're gonna want that app
for new year's eve tomorrow rick the
show is being sponsored by
my pillow my pillow if you don't have
a my pillow that you you definitely have
to get one
um if you rather have a topper for your
bed
i suggest you go out and get a topper uh
they also are selling giza sheets
use a cotton sheet i won't get one free
for
your bed makes you feel like that you
are in a hotel
uh my pillow uh
just call them 1-800-889-0532
use the promo code wayne if you are
having any issues
let us know email me wayne
wayne dupree.com again if you have any
issues
email me or sit or send me a message i'm
using the app
uh let us know if you're having any
issues
with your order please uh if you have
won something what
if you want something in the past uh or
if you have ordered something before
christmas and you don't have it
let us know we need to know okay
um again we want to thank our patreon
members
adrian theodora and anne thank you
thank you 500 patreon members we're
asking
you to join any way you can
just go to patreon.com forward slash wd
show the the money that
we uh collect there pays
for us to continue to do what we do and
to keep us moving
on the air i want to also thank our
our um our guy today
um ace ace ace is the place
yeah asa the man ace sponsored the show
today
big time so thank you
yeah okay all right might have to make
you part of the show man
big dog um
perry says a friend of mine slept on a
mattress topper last night and her back
feels
so much better uh she said that it was
worth the 200 bucks
so believe me uh actually
if it was 200 it was more than that it
was a reduced rate
well then you also get there's like a
package deal where you get extra pillows
yeah you get two regular sized pillows
yeah that's cool all right so again
tomorrow make sure that you tune into
the show
and with out with the old in with the
new the wayne the pre-show
anybody have any last thoughts real
quick uh i did some research while you
were talking on that airplane thing
the airplanes have hepa filters that's
it um
pretty much like every other restaurant
and the reason why it's more dangerous
on an airplane is because you're on
there longer and you're compact
versus a restaurant where air flows uh
more smooth
freely yeah more freely um
so i just wanted to make sure i had that
right and i did some research on it and
yeah
your furnace and or your air conditioner
will pull and draw the air from outside
of your house
to then condition it to either be hot or
cold take the humidity out
or whatnot so it's drawing air from
outside
aircraft don't do that right that's the
same aircraft don't do that
and my last thought mark levine has left
the facebooks
he's got 4.2 million followers on the
parlor
only 2.8 on the twitters and 1.6 on the
facebook so he's big on the parlors
i'm just bringing that up because
y'all the purge is going to happen
sooner or later regardless
of 2 30 or not 2 30 prepare yourself
just like you would
buy extra water or extra toilet paper or
extra whatever
in your house prepare yourselves are you
sure he left facebook because
he claims he's been he's been saying
that for
almost a year or so so i'm
i think he still has his facebook page
he's just
tweeting out well leave here's the thing
you can
you can claim to delete your facebook
page but other people can see it for a
while it's like a 30 days
like 30 days yeah
just it is what it is if he comes back
but the whole point
i'm trying to make y'all need to go
follow us on the parlors
on pure social on parlor on
what's the other ones damn there's just
so many up there's a whole lot of them
out there
there's too many there's too many wayne
dupree
leah bella bella and i am brian smith
[Music]
smyth
you